cute celery sign you will report on top
most of defendants
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody good morning as you can
tell so we're playing some fighting
games today hello guys what's up good
morning happy Monday Persia here I'm
joined by Shady K from anyway game's
combat developer alongside clockwork
which is who you guys are usually seeing
on the stream day but no we got shady
today because of breaking down the new
DLC character Eric Myers and I heard you
know this is like your dude yes it's
like your your heart and soul right here
so yes might need to get a little closer
to the mic and so yes take it away
Shady's already clearly going ham right
now it's character why not Oh Brandon
remembers you from the Extra Life stream
spicy Cain that's a very named you this
place you can realize oh I still can't
believe it was a great time besides the
fact that I was it was crazy but yes
nebula says quantum power am i right so
yeah tell us a little bit more about
this besides he's totally cable s that's
got some things yeah complicated
dancing moves like a gun guy needs a
board game super oh nice okay okay kind
of like got some layers and so during
this guy to behold special and kept down
yeah actually actually dodge buzz
because that protect all invisible for a
little bit and ducks and then you can
tell where it out there Wow what so fair
player character I'm gonna move this
camera for you guys really quick because
I realize is in the wrong spot this
board specialist keselowksi dippel's
have
big one April
they fix the camera y'all
yes we're good so yeah but yeah if you
guys they don't make rye you might
recognize his characters danced out
versus actually what to major before he
was Virgil the gaga guy in the chat says
it's be Shady
indeed it is
yeah actually been doing the voiceover
being rose on the to Gavin so yeah we
also have Rose here who helps over at in
weight games she'd be running the show
over there her hand okay sits right
there she is amazing she helps keep all
of the information intact so in case you
guys don't know along with this brand
new character we also have some patch
notes and other hot fixes bug fixes and
updates it's it's a pretty heavy lips so
I'm gonna throw this link in chat but
yeah we think the soft lock with Jason
throwing quantum so that's pretty
important
okay had a lot of good changes people
really liked it now I think any message
in social media about the meta being
actually pretty yeah Marvel games would
be crazy crazy though it's it's great
though
rémi gaming says what's up Persia and
shady K how's everything everything is
great
hope you guys are doing great too thanks
for tuning in and just seeing a lot of
general love right now for Power Rangers
which is totally amazing especially for
those who don't know that this game
exists right so paradox says is this a
Power Rangers game question mark yes it
is and it's it's pretty awesome
especially if you love fighting games
and vs fighters it kind of hits and
checks every box yet it's amazing right
there's a parent just waiting game lord
zedd good I've heard it so I've heard
but yeah a lot of Marvel folks love this
game
huh amazing like I don't know it makes
me want to cry I can meet this game for
them you know and they like it
definitely worth the pickup especially
if you're a Power Rangers fan and a
fighting game fan even if you're not a
fighting game fan I'd still recommend it
it's pretty cool they have a lot of the
original voice actors for these
characters and are always coming out
with updates and DLC brand new
characters like all the time how many
characters are you guys in no 2 DLC and
as you know content and the way for this
game so definitely check it out what do
you guys think he's gonna play like any
way of dicing bands the question of all
questions I mean he looks like a cumin
to me so
so I I'll bow I am enjoying your combos
here yeah you're not using the carrot
just show ah there we go
so who do you think are the best
characters to play with Eric this is a
wall bounce and you can pretty good
Feeny's really good pitches like that
Red's pretty good anyone who can also
hand off
[Music]
I need more than once entire yes it's
bad
yeah he's a good assist and good anchor
I think he was designed with what he
needs to get space good kind of a stoner
like he's normally really bad isn't if
you with the easily oh yeah he's a
methodical character right I'm
definitely getting Gomorrah vibe oh yeah
yeah a shark for sure which is fun I
played her an infant she was on my man's
but yeah so it's like Chris Redfield
misses the Laura mixed with cable mix
with Virgil you know in essence yeah
yeah in heart and in rapid slash
[Laughter]
yeah we're gonna play yes so we are
gonna play some games against you guys
who wants to play let us know we'll give
you guys a few minutes to boot up your
consoles we're playing on ps4 today so
yeah yeah in the meantime we'll play
some rings while you guys get booted up
um I think we're playing on my n way
profile which is Persia hashtag 57 57
score for the easy to remember name but
yes Anna hello Bob Jones word up welcome
back
nebith said only vibe I'm getting is
Virgil hey you know Shady's lucky this
is my job and I have to feature such
character you know that's not true
but yeah all right so we're displacing
some online rings gotta you know boost
my stats here and let us know if you
guys gonna get some games in feel free
to add us oh are you gonna lose your
first match you can't lose on my account
alright that's the first first rule of
business alright we've got Eric Myers in
raw launch on incoming us I'm talking oh
now hold that he had the reads on you
can't just be throwing throws scrubber
what are you a combat
and Richie said what you can't fight in
the command center it's a place of peace
[Laughter]
yeah god I do like the voice for all of
the like super and stuff yeah I'm not
gonna live from the first time we stream
this game to now it has come a long way
it was still good to before but I could
definitely like it's so much more
marveling I love that's enough rest yup
you won I know thank you thank you knock
yes this is Power Rangers battle for the
grid the 3v3 versus fighting game oh man
I got scared I thought there was a bug
in our light but it's not okay we're
good I think out of the corner of my eye
are freaking me out a little bit we're
good
no bugs here you guys alright alright so
first victim down warm up spin got the
brand new DLC character on the squad oh
look it's my anchor quantum Ranger you
know I put Eric Myers in the in the
title okay good
cuz I was like maybe I should have
picked quantum quantum Rangers like a
secondary title/subtitle I guess you
know I'm throwing his whole government
out there alright it's fine oh it is Oh
play me again no we're on internet send
us all the way back through the title
screen let's go Wow yes start a 55 we
are playing on ps4 today if you guys
want to get some games in with us let us
know should we check o to see if anyone
has go back yeah let's go down to our
two there we go wait I don't have anyone
- oh yeah so on PlayStation for it you
have to add on in way and you have to
add us on ps4 itself that's the other
thing is you so while we take a look at
the friend requests to see if any of you
guys have added us we're taking them
like right now don't want to expose my
you know
alright no one's out of this I mean fine
I get it but if you do it's Persia EXO
and then add us on anyway at Persia EXO
hashtag 5757
alright back to the game we're back to
rings until you guys send us some
requests yeah I'm gold one is that good
put in work that's way star 55 two fives
gonna add us oh I don't know why I added
that extra 55 I think it was my username
on anyway this in my brain the star 55
stays gonna add us cool we will look at
that after this game Hollywood rock
another oh snap rows with the Intel was
like this guy's good by the way
oh yes really great its Krueger really
in the game
yeah right that's an even that your guy
you guys just put out right Anubis yeah
yes p.m. steric many guys ed that's been
probably one of my favorite like
characters you guys have added cuz he's
like pretty like goofy and wonky but
he's also really good right Thank You
star we'll take a look at that after
this game I like how Rose hyped up this
guy and then shady you're like all right
let's see you about that little tribal
already darling characters oh no oh
sorry I think you think you've met the
guy you got justice I was like he's
destroying this guy does man
oh no joke said in his ps4 blew up or
I'll see what it gave you
oh yeah sounds like a likely existed
scrubs Frank ass not Frank Castle since
I'm liking this game looks cool I would
definitely recommend checking it out
it's really fun Frank Castle this is on
switch so thumbs up he said if it's on
switch I'm getting it it most definitely
is it's available on all platforms feels
so good to say that physique on full
xbox pc ps4 the switch at your grandma's
house set you know at the worst place
everywhere oh snap Killick Wabo said I
might have to buy this game so I can
play y'all do it let's go we still got a
long stream ahead of us plenty of body
bags for you guys alright oh dang no
heads up no nothing jeez sorry alright
so yeah okay yeah it's okay guys this is
Shady's first ps4 I think you accepted
okay
all right so we actually just accepted
Rama's go easy on me anyway sorry
it's friend requests and then our eats
you
[Music]
yeah I have a list there well yeah
technical tips do you have to restart
the game or the whole console all right
well yeah go for it we're gonna restart
the console real quick yeah go for it
oh I'm like you have the controls okay
go to the power yeah there we go
all right guys so we're just gonna
restart this constant really quick so
that in with like and then yeah we're
still accepting friend requests we're
gonna try to see if the restart will
help get our in way play friends list a
pop-up so we can accept your invites and
yeah there is okay there is cross play
for this game cross play works across
every single platform
except ps4 so spur now sorry you guys um
you know I'm more so of just like a big
fan of ps4 right now so that's why we're
playing on it probably should for future
streams play on like PC or something so
we can cross play with you guys but yeah
there is cross play just not for ps4
right now apologies we are restarting
and yeah oh squishy said with that
glitch you just have to reset that all
good all good you know restart never
hurt anybody if anything the consoles is
thanking us for the quick breather yeah
this game is too much for it all this
ham this the consoles like with
oh sweet tillich Wabo said you got my
name right first try great job why thank
you I'm bad it means we really been all
right boom checking online service we
got that just go the next thing why I
tell you is this star 55 hey I thought I
saw reme gaming in the chat Oh someone
knows earlier
so we'll go check again oh nice
so I heard clockwork was losing a lot
last time we're gonna continue that
tradition all right challenge accepted
all right are you about to get it taught
how to use your own little 431 Jesus bro
we good I just make it alright star
after this one I swear we were gonna go
see a piece we didn't see your friend
close to person that we looked but we
did restart everything so it might pop
up this time
[Music]
honestly I think one of the coolest
things about this game is that you know
the developers are fighting game players
they know the cheapness they know what's
a you know add what's he going out of
experience we tried to hit you with the
with the mix ups you're like now I gotta
measure they got a meter bro
oh no oh okay
see some pizzazz with your girl again
don't shy to meeting this boy you know
I'm seeing a trend this is wake up he
eggs too strong job said I miss my ps4
Friday can't come fast enough can you
I'll play this enough again another day
so I can get in next time I'm sure that
battle for the grid will definitely be
back we like to have them on to feature
your new DLCs and updates and all that
good stuff and they're constantly you
know on the grind providing that fresh
content so I without a doubt know if you
guys would be back again so hopefully
you can tune in with us next time oh
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
yeah I know people in entire Lake get
them Remy another like correction
Shady's lives best game ever yeah that
were cats it by myself
[Laughter]
shady is like offline only but plays
like an online person yeah that candid
compliment keep them humble yeah
oh my god
oh snap Wow
uh-huh
yo don't be so quick to see that squishy
squishy said start your I last hope I
don't know this game we are all PPK I
love the noise baby oh come back time
come back down whoa oh my god
[Music]
stomp on him
ooh noise your lives or did you yes yes
oh snap we got a lever freaking laying
in the chat what is good Oliver thanks
for joining us he said his I o'clock
voicing their puddy
we did have fun doing the putty
impressions last time clock as iostream
all right so it's one one right now by
the way this is the set this guy's
reckon is pretty good
oh yeah now we have to blame Kailash ah
thanks Trish Trish so this is the best
channel on YouTube while you are da bomb
calm for your amazing compliments much
appreciated Happy Mondays
oh it's Monday you guys what are your
goals for the week feel like my goal for
this week is to do some exercise I have
been so lazy and been eating so much
it's not good I need to move the muscle
and get the blood flowing you know I'm
not gonna go him not bodybuilder status
or anything but I feel like I need to do
some activity maybe technical difficulty
oh boy oh boy oh no disconnect and
reconnect
I know Thank You Remy for being a pal oh
no sign back in yeah usually when you
unplug it you go same back end there we
go okay hey Thank You Remy you for
waiting
I know school honorable I would have
taken that W you already know how I work
Edwin says my goal for this week is to
get first at my local nice good luck
wishing you the best what game are you
playing curious and what region is your
local and also curious also battle for
the grid players in NorCal there's gonna
be a battle for the grid tournament at
Wednesday night Wednesday night fights
this week so don't miss it set eSports
Arena in Oakland oh no it's always
something after he was so like nice and
accommodating all right we got a restart
that last match and then we're gonna get
star in here and after that Kevin said
my goal is get shady came out to a local
and had people regret their fighting
game character choices oh all day not
Frank Castle said I'm finally gonna
watch the Joker this weekend noise I
actually still haven't seen it I do want
to see it it's been causing like an
uproar I noticed though since it was
released so I'm so curious
Oliver said more training as always
Oliver is always on the grind
Church is your goal to eat food because
that's a great goal even though it's a
little opposite of mine this week that's
the goal I would do just because
Oh Adams a BBF see you Tekken 7 smash
ultimate and peace in Sacramento oh snap
so you can get first in all of those
thing Derek is it really your birthday
happy birthday if you're playing des
stranding and you put your birthday in
there they'll give you a birthday cake
when you go into your private room it's
pretty cool
Omega black says who's playing at the
moment Shea DK is playing this is
actually the first time we've had shady
gay on GameSpot live to help promote new
DLC characters for a battle for the grid
usually we have clockwork on board but
shady is also a combat developer and the
newest character Eric Myers aka quantum
Ranger who were who we have on the
screen at the moment is basically like
Shady's characters so pretty cool have
you guys face off against him we are
taking requests for a gameplay you can
add us on the in week games
server at Persia XO hashtag 5757
and on ps4 since that's what we're
playing today at Persia exo-k's
Omega says I need to get a piece of
shady well yeah an hour we've got an
hour left of this dream plenty of time
to match some buttons all right that's
two one are we doing yep
two out of three Gigi's although he
needs the last one and stick scooter she
said I'm sorry anything shady kiss Chuck
Norris okay okay yeah I might to check
friend requests yeah we're checking our
friend requests on PlayStation Network
I'm a star I don't see your request
maybe
oh wait wait I think I saw it you might
have sent me one along yeah oh wait yeah
sorry
okay cool you must have added a slash
stream I'm sorry if you like that
sometimes all right so we back all right
and then Gucci in the chat what up what
up do I need to do anything on my end I
feel like it should show that he's
online hey star we've added you are you
still online oh oh we have to add you on
anyway as well I suppose
oh there we go oh there we go so squishy
said Chuck Norris can do anything that
was the relation saving okay that's not
true you know Adam Jensen yes this is
the Power Rangers battle for the grid
three-on-three versus fighting game in
case you don't know oh okay
also follow battle for the grid on
Twitter you guys it's battle number for
the grid and apparently there's a lot of
sales going on for the game right now so
head there and you know check it out
what up ninja how's it going Gucci says
who am i seeing at NEC
because there is an official side
tournament at NEC this year yeah getting
the seal of approval and all of my
information here Wow I tried to do some
promotion and I look back and you did
like what happened we lost a character
already it's okay it wasn't the DLC
characters I think we're good specific
talk more about the tournament so Stefan
well if you guys do not know what NEC is
that is the Northeast championships and
that tournament has been going on
forever it goes alongside the other two
tournaments that Big E gaming runs and
it's amazing I've been to a lot of any
C's I've been to a lot of summer jams
been to a lot of winter brawls
so all those tournaments are really
really good and it's pretty exciting
that it's gonna be an official side
tournament for this game there I can't
wait for this game and start getting
more love and local tournaments
especially with how much it's evolved
since its release and that's been in you
know just under a year right in this
game came out like March or something
yeah so I'm excited hey yeah Moochie
games running that side tournament and
me at any seeds holding it down to the
community Wednesday next black oh it is
this month I can't wait to see the first
baby starve it's going he's gonna win
[Laughter]
I'm so happy the game now it is exciting
Squishy's that I have PTSD from storage
level 671 let's go is it infinite amount
of level sure
yo alright so just got word from the
boss lady in charge she said every four
weeks these levels get inside is that
factual because well obviously is I just
heard okay because I was like ding you
racked up that many levels in four weeks
you are a tail mic be in the chat web
how's it going
then just said this game lacks a good
meaty grappler oh wow that's an
interesting teeth
I feel like nuts I feel like what the
wave meters are in this game like you
should never count on something me
[Applause]
Bucci says hi rose
can carry on a background
um yes the DLC for Eric Myers is
available it is out and about is a part
of the universe and it can be yours
today please feel free to go pop down
and there's even where they'll be on the
way you guys like the TLC behind this
game is amazing
what is up superhuman how goes it
oh my god
Lorde's all right pixel come back let's
go
[Laughter]
that's who our are yeah Oh ding the
options too busy developing characters
all right who's next who's oh and star I
said it was laggy dang he beat your ass
thank you right after
oof the combos are real unblockable
unblockable yo squishy we see your
online boy I think I don't know I just
assumed
Mike Susan rich has been practicing for
this month
dang yeah you know how would you rate
stars play no he's really good I've been
watching him stream the game for a while
oh snap he's been watching you you know
not logged in on Twitch he just goes
into your chat and lurks yeah so you
can't find them in the viewer list
stealing all your combos on the low
we're gonna check the friends list wins
white white ranger skin dropping so zoo
teams soon TM yeah Omega black it's all
on the way oh oh
screw cheese day is eating you know I
trying to get his energy up
take those carbs in before you you know
he serves you some hands
it's all getting get that nutrition in
we will be here Starr said Shady what do
you think about the snapback combo that
I found for Zedd oh man all that stuff
like man you guys post so much stuff
went through I don't even think of most
of that stuff that's kind of the best
part yeah people just discovering the
snap combos are similar to schoolgirls
or interesting Oh Evan also Oh everybody
bleed I know the sharks are out the
sharks are out squid she said I'll play
while I eat I don't even care now you
gotta wait now rocky Yuki hello welcome
happy Monday hope you're having a
wonderful day wherever you're at get
ready to fight whoa whoa beast what the
hot takes nerf cat nerf magnet nerf
Gold's are that sounds like a very
specific match sent you over the edge
like someone with that exact team made
you just like rage Alice and I feel it
just tastes like salt plate Marvel you
know zero may cry pops onto the screen
I'm like each and every one of these
characters need to be nervous wait
except for zombie though he's had enough
oh snap I'm so busy looking at chat I
didn't even know what was going on what
am i dead
it's okay guys we're the good news is
we're paying attention to him yeah sorry
you guys had to come back to to this
massacre oh my god what happened I guess
I should have paid an age restriction on
this stream this intensive is the
straight murder we have here oh it's
like that you're gonna be a mess on the
stream Evan I'm gonna remember that now
it's time to you better switch it off
after this where pick your best I mean
my game so what am I gonna do all that
great give me as many times well you
think you're getting out of it but maybe
20 bucks
Abuk in the chat see he was even like
please don't see that he did it
Soji not to do it outraged
[Music]
the animated violence needs age
restriction no it's not the animation
since the pure like disrespect the
disrespect is violence be said tried to
tell you I need work down some power no
one once against refund yeah not right
he was like a word my job here is done
I'm out you know I respect a good one
and done I know why I do that all the
time
oh no one likes alright who is up next I
know I'm mega black got on to play
squishy did send us an invite eventually
if Evans Eve icy winds is the law so
it's a big well on to the next one then
he didn't want to get downloaded I
respect it it's a it's an actual tactic
it'd be like that sometimes
and then just said I still need to laugh
this game more insane what's going on
loaded we are a chinchilla in playing
some battle for the grid new dlc Eric
Myers quantum Ranger everyone who's been
playing since blood yes good now I'm so
happy is like the best like seeing
everyone's do optimal stuff but I
couldn't playing the game house meant to
be played I feel like you can be harder
probably for the developers you like
find some of the stuff you guys find
when they've built in a specific way you
need fresh eyes on things I see I see
you
Linda's saying only a few characters are
really clicking with him which is why
he's wishing for a true grappler yeah
you know sometimes I feel like I only go
for a specific archetype in terms of
characters and fighting hands and when I
don't find that in a game I think it's
more up to me to kind of expand my
repertoire or expand my skill set and
kind of you know find something that I
can make my own you know depending on my
level of love through the game of course
yeah don't be afraid to step outside the
box
Oh No hey what what I'm sorry said shady
as long as you hear us
we'll definitely support you guys all
the way until we in that's so sweet
it's true too
I feel like especially with all the
updates and stuff you guys have done
everything's been a massive improvement
from the one before in ways that
everyone once so they're listing anyway
it's good stuff
Oh
mr. pip says ding I have to catch y'all
next stream well we're still gonna be
streaming for a little while now oh he's
at work never mind don't get fired
I feel you man good I feel you well
luckily there's more stuff on the way
more characters on the way I love his
ways
a big said wit with the X moves to e^x
move and that play doesn't even shaky
you know there's something that's about
the you know online world it brings up
the the heart
MPC already once oh no whoa oh it's uh
oh man you know I had
NPC wants to try out dice she already I
feel yeah oh snap the comebacks sorry
Rocky Yuki
there will be more streams in the future
we love fighting games and we let battle
5th grade what's this was at the first
game yeah okay that's all in the long
game
let's go mega black sea sky all the time
in this bird
Oh
[Music]
baby are you on a hitbox yes he is
exposed everyone always says like
blocking cross-ups is higher in the box
yes you heard here first
cross up shady as many times yeah it's
like this it feels natural again big I
tried I tried to learn hitbox my brain
could not compute
I didn't have the patience to stick with
it long enough to add us to play just
give us an ad on the in wait with our
inlay ID which is Persia XO hashtag 57
57 and then also add us on PSN which is
just Persia itself then just a time
first think is pretty anime thanks to
her err -
does the game have a story mode yes yes
okay
yes I complete story mode is available
for this game did y'all get the actual
actors from the show for this game I
know that some of the characters mostly
the ones from the original roster right
oh yeah so a big chunk of the original
roster and like a few other characters
were all voiced by their actual people
you know voice actors so like Red Ranger
right I was in red Rangers you know we
all love Jason
why are you lol a man dang-son lol
against it how about that cinema back at
you just trying to spread some details a
different base any guys but yeah it's
not original basis for every single
character but it's a good amount which
is pretty cool he's got like a little
bit of everyone he's got the same oh
snap he's got the doom Jer
you got like you know Felicia with those
little pity helpers and you got me you
got me one one
oh yeah the discord you guys let me go
see if I can find because Fucci said the
discord is almost had 2000 members which
is pretty good am I gonna live discards
a lot of work also by the way to
maintain and manage so extra props you
for that it's no joke
I tried to with EXO it's in work you
like me people really dedicated to that
and I was bad
um so yeah guys check out that discord
if you are interested in meeting some
more members of the community getting
the lowdown on you know combos or
anything else I know when I first
started playing this game everybody so
super chill help me out with learning
the things I wanted to learn and they're
all just super nice and they're really
supporting the game of the community so
check
Oh
Oh Oh No oh there was a lot going on
there for a moment nothing like a good
old snapback oh come on
wake up bro Wow Oh
oh snap
tidy
Adam you come to our extreme so often
and you said oh no my name is Persia I
mean I love that you come back and hang
out with us
hi Adam Persia I feel like if I were to
play this more I would definitely pick
this chick oh yeah I'm cool to be
slicing and dicing all right Rocky he
thank you for tuning in geez have a good
day at work
I'd love to theorycraft with you guys
about possibilities but it's like not
possible I've learned a lot from yeah
sure let's check the friends list let's
see if I remember to change this camera
back to the game on time yeah weird
where's our - on this thing home button
GG's Omega black we Ranger says I'm
happy this game continues to get love
and hope it keeps getting better I'm
seeing these recent ones yes
except all those babble was well known
there's like 30 more but the ones from
today yeah let's go Omega said shady Zeo
scares me
alrighty oh yeah
okay squishy wants a piece of the action
now squishy is um has eaten he's nice
and full he's ready I really could pop
gums I mean I'm definitely not good at
finding games anymore I used to be at
least like decent enough to carry my own
and now I'm just a scrubs you just touch
it to everybody else it's what I do
wanna come catch these hands from Shady
[Laughter]
squishy why'd you eat
I got a no what is the the gamer fuel
for your match
oh well it happens Omega especially all
playing online but it's alright you
forgot at least 30 more minutes Oh
scream and we can get a run back in
there and we'll see
Oh Mary so for those of you in chat
curious about what the roster looks like
currently in the game keep this link for
the information that your heart desires
we got Jason Lee Scott gia Morgan or
Gaea
okay I'm I've been watching a lot you
know playing on a mythical game surnames
or just not what I remember the honey
gold our Magna defender mastodons
century they know you know who Donna is
one of my personal faves also but yeah
check it out definitely more to come
guys she is not out yet but you can see
what that she looks like looking pretty
epic
it's like Akuma Black Panther I'm all
mixed together I'm ready wait
I was like what happened um no body bag
that's what happens rematch in there
I remember when I was younger and I used
to watch the show but you know I wasn't
like diehard power ranger fan like I've
seen every episode I just specifically
remember watching a show when I was
younger and then I tried to like make up
my own Power Rangers persona it was that
because I wanted to be a Power Ranger I
wanted to be like a purple Ranger so
there wasn't one but I honestly don't
know if I even came up with the name but
I was just like how can we call purple
Ranger I want to be a purple Ranger I
know see this is a long time ago
why you laying down for sleeping on the
job
oh snap FTC set so in the chat what a I
think that's from all I think question
why usually he said Eric became so
popular on ranked overnight very good
denying thank you
like a madman like I mix back there on
oh we got some debate oh yeah there's my
little no eric is more afraid Lorenzo
I'll give you that
and then advic psych Eric fair question
we're gonna Lola I mean he's more fair
than Virgil oh yeah if you're comparing
them side by side there's no contest I
don't know what game Virgil was designed
to be in it was like he was in his own
game when everybody else was just
playing in there I am right next oh yeah
who's next who is that um ha oh sit yeah
either loaded or mega Isaac we're gonna
shoot one of you guys an invite whoever
accepts yeah let's try loaded first I
did see him say something in the chat
earlier
except this banana see she's going in
this head oh yeah anybody in chat going
to NEC to enter is this the first
official like Cyberman at a major and oh
yeah yeah well one of the first another
big event
another big tournament okay I would I'd
let you load a TV we are sending you a
direct challenge
please accept oh nice
so if enough people go to NEC and enter
then expect some more Power Rangers
goodness at biggie tournaments and if
you guys don't know who Big E is or what
Big E gaming is then go to Big E gaming
calm they host regional on the East
Coast tournaments like three times a
year that's just on Big E gaming side
but they also do a lot of collaboration
work with final round and chin Wonka
with tournaments like final round on TFC
and stuff like that so just a lot of
funny game actually going on at East
Coast so check it out
Jose said I just started playing this
game this weekend I really like it
awesome definitely a great time to start
picking up this game lots of goodies and
more on the way
Jamal said I believe about it for the
grid will also be a frosty fastings new
noise shout outs to frosty
oh yeah that's right hoc he's been doing
battle for the grid shout out the bum
and New York holding it down
I know y'all like the ham miss and you
can perfect for you guys I know right
this game has HSE written all over it to
be fair
oh yeah and if you guys do host your own
milk bowls or you have tournament near
you
make sure you tag battle for the grid on
Twitter then they're always on playing
with sharing the love sending out the
retweets letting people know that you
know your tournaments happening so don't
be shy roses got your back all right but
don't harass her positivity only this
game needs more time for us
all right these things take time
yeah these things take time
forests if you will no no no no don't
enable me don't time for sit oh I know
that it's really getting out of control
you know there's part of my brain I got
damaged a long time ago and it all
spawns out of there I think I'm pretty
sure I blame the chili vodka
yikes Oh kill me kill your master
oh nice opera then Wow he's like look at
what you've done did you look at what
you're created who's next
plans on Adams king of the hill what is
that
Oh oh no backlash on wakeup twice out
now we good now we good we push bak use
all the meters I do think the cool thing
about busienss us there's so many
Rangers to choose from at this point
that the possibilities can be endless
like why not spread his game who knows
come true Oh stomping on him
oh and that what's the score one way one
to one that's a good said low dudes
playing kind of nice I'll snap these
guys get thrown clicks yeah right he's
sitting the whole song to get their
clout for me right now like y'all go
join the stream and play right now so
you can flip this for your highlight
reel you said loaded has to be recruited
hey we're all about you know help you
make opportunities happen he recruited
bro oh no it's gonna be of a classic
people in the chat gave you props loaded
during the back - on wakeup is the tech
we discovered something oh he's already
a part of it are an array he's already
recruited now he's just trying to uphold
the name yes Power Rangers clout I
really don't get it
I need more the shooter
oh yeah he's like slow down a second oh
no I said Lassiter
oh yeah lucky there
husband said the revolution is happening
what revolution with an agenda colliding
people for this they saved all of this
specifically for when shady was on the
stream there was no revolution when
class you guys make a statue of me and
and then try to take it down all right
to one GPU qgs loaded looks like we got
time for one or two more matches um a
dark night the new character is that
we're kind of featuring and celebrating
for today's stream is Eric Myers quantum
Ranger mega is a Kristen and un invite
we are sending you a direct challenge
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh snap like Power Rangers battle for
the grid actual official tissue account
is up in our chat right now send in
those eye emojis they're like don't be
spilling no information that isn't
approved we're watching you oh oh I
think so I mean he did send us an invite
a friend requests as requested by us to
the stream so taking all challenge he's
a love 183 so it's not like you know
someone just opened up the game and was
like yeah let me invite this which
totally fine if you guys onion
no fear I'm like not even sure I want to
know what STC stands for yeah and you
know I've been hesitant to even ask and
that wasn't an official ask
I'm just saying I don't know what it
stands for and I'm scared
that was a perfect job yeah I beginning
to go straight with those whoo let's go
see you worse
oh yeah Chris squishes low back that you
guys you know tuned in last minute I
know he didn't really promote this too
much beforehand but you guys showed up
for sure it's been awesome
awesome
cool
trying to charge up the gun rain
quicklink Tyrannosaurus I can't help but
just repeat what they say sometimes
Richard yes this game is definitely
worth picking up it's fun if I
definitely think this is one of the you
know a few vs. fighters that is pretty
accessible I know it could be daunting
to pick up a bracelet fighters
especially three-on-three it's like a
lot of characters to learn if you're not
really used to that type of thing but
this game does a good job at kind of
balancing that
Jamal says what are we getting more air
- characters stop being such a Marvel
Blair alright just kidding come on just
kidding
oh snap nice work
oh no that's messy too hard
hey you got me gotta finish the combo
firm all right very nice - mega Isaac
got that back there actually right for
those first games yeah Oh
here's uh yeah we do got some sales
going on if you want the lowdown on all
the sales and stuff like that the
Twitter is probably the best place for
you guys to check it out go to at battle
number four the grid - check it out
mega Isaac up one oh right now over
shady Evan again says the revolution is
mega I think a part of your revolution
as well is out what's happening
Oh
snapping squishy hope you have a good
day
GG's he said he's off to Veterans Day
shenanigans yeah happy Veterans Day
everybody gotta send out my personal
things after this stream of my homies
you've done a great service for us
throughout the years it's really
something that should be celebrated like
more than this Monday I'm also guilty of
that really only showing my appreciation
on this day but you guys know ya know
holidays
hello Robin so apparently Isaac is
actually a part of the three founding
fathers of this revolution that event
thinking about it's fair no I don't want
any further this is like there's some
there is some lawyer here well start
sanitarium move me all right one one
Lord Evan JD's trying to stop the
revolution from one of the founding
fathers yo y'all really went like into
lawyer founding fathers that's epic
oh dang
everybody jump the revolution it starts
now
noise yes do the e^x loaded said GG is
shading Gigi's letter speaking on behalf
of him as he fights the revolution he's
a founding father after all
Oh cries I'm telling you sort of like
hitbox problems it's really easy to do
ozx moves on hitbox Oh No
has he played the flute there's Matt
don't worry about it oh snap oh Evanson
Isaac did it for the organization they
really Slyke infiltrated today
well GG's GG's the revolution is growing
stronger who else is on the list so we
really only have time for like one more
match um do we one take a look at the
friends list to see if anybody your gave
you clear although we've taken like
thirty screenshots and video clips by
accident let's see did we get anybody
else in here no we did not
all right who wants to throw hands for
last match of the game let us know chat
let us know is the revolution still out
here yes sorry do you wanna just run a
final ranked match and then call it a
day all right cool this gun you know
just fighting an online match for the
last match of the day thank you guys so
much for tuning in with us today though
it's been really really fun you guys are
all awesome showing up big for a battle
for the grid yeah thanks for all the
support guys you guys are the best
so excited to see the first heard of it
I want to see you good Howard Rangers in
space featuring a crossover episode with
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles uh uh
now that would be a crossover I'd play
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles versus
Power Ranger favorite turtle hey why
isn't Michelangelo wait I'm being
profiled by my favorite turtle that's
crazy
no it's true that the personality right
yeah that's true and he was smart I
respect that
Master Splinter a little I've got a
respect you know single dads out there
putting in that work
oMG are we oh there we go match very
nice game
honored essence number one level 130
he's gonna get recruited my job
Oh StuCo tuning in for the last five
minutes love the stream thank you for
tuning there yeah we might have to
recruit honored essence if they land a
blow to the revolution
[Music]
step aside oh dang
oh man I got to Betsy hi
because I'm recruited already no not you
thinking about honoured essence unless
this is not you oh snap
you won't be able to post links into
this chat oven so sorry and also don't
even know what sec sent for and I ain't
gonna post nothing in this chat no you
behaving
Oh synaptic anyway hold that oh yeah
you know that's an easy jump in oh my
god so let him do it see ya he's been
lochia prior there's a plan I know
Barnes I write you guys that is actually
gonna be it for us today but good games
to everyone
it was awesome time happy Monday by the
way and thanks for tuning in
every weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time
you can catch us here on gamespot live
and play a bunch of different things all
the time so yeah thank you guys so much
have a good one and we will see you
tomorrow